does cancel culture exist it it's
incredible to me that anyone would deny
that it exists when the evidence is so
overwhelming
for it um i've i've been in
conversations with people about this
online and
there's a couple of threads online which
have hundreds and hundreds of examples
of
of people who've lost their jobs uh out
of um for something they've said at work
or something that's
uh you know of course it exists i mean
quite obviously i think you you know the
the main complaint of saying well no
one's been cancelled again that's
someone taking a metaphor literally
no one's saying that anyone is literally
being canceled council culture is a
shorthand
metaphor for a a form a method whereby
when you hear something that offends you
upsets you typically something quite
innocuous or relatively inconsequential
in other words part of cancer culture is
an overreaction right so
so you go in organs blazing and you
don't stop until that person has lost
everything their livelihood their job
their reputation
absolutely it's all got to go because
there can be no redemption there can be
no forgiveness
and this happens again and again and the
examples of it are so
numerous that it is impossible to deny
with a straight face that it doesn't
exist and yet people do
you know it's for this it's the same
reason i mean you know people
hate to say it again but write writers
for the guardian will continually say
cancer culture doesn't exist because
they are its chief practitioners
you know remember this is a publication
that when suzanne moore wrote that
article which they all disliked
most of the staff wrote a letter of
complaint to try and get her booted out
and then it's the same people who will
say that cancer culture doesn't exist
well well this is hardly surprising
because the culture war is largely
engineered and motored by people like
the people who work at the guardian it's
their culture war this is the
identitarian left's culture war
but they are the same people who will
say the culture war is a right-wing myth
but they're they're the antagonists it's
it's nuts but
jk rowling's said loads of stuff she
hasn't been cancelled why is she not
being cancelled
well you know the answer to that chris
she's a billionaire
and uh as we all know council culture
overwhelmingly affects poor people
and this is the other major myth about
it you know if you're a celebrity put
someone in the public guy who is
financially secure
uh it's very difficult to cancel you
know you can't cancel get jk rowling
she's the richest richest author in the
world
you can however cancel jillian phillip
who's the scottish author
who tweeted in support of j k rowling
says she lost her publisher
and she lost her age that can happen uh
because she's she's expendable
you can't no publisher in their right
mind would get rid of jk rowling so no
she cannot be cancelled
but that does not justify that the uh
the venomous misogynistic abuse she gets
on a daily basis i mean that's still
on a human level just morally
unforgivable
however she she isn't subject to cancer
culture i will accept i will accept that
and um
the ones who are subject to cancer
culture are normally people who don't
have the means to stick up for
themselves who don't have the financial
resources to do so
who are intimidated because they go into
work and suddenly they're facing a
tribunal because someone overheard
something they said
and and and misinterpreted
misinterpreted it this isn't about
someone who's gone into work and starts
shouting about [ __ ] and puffs and
and and how they should all be killed
and stuff that's the way it's portrayed
no it's someone who made a joke that
someone's
misinterpreted as being homophobic
because it hurt their feelings
and so they went and that you know it's
a different thing and it may not even
have been about gay people at all right
it's the the key
aspects of cancer culture is that the
slight is actually often
very small right and also it's it's
possible i mean there's um
a lot of people are talking about how we
should we should not have call out
culture we should have call in culture
and actually it sounds a bit tacky but
there's something in that insofar as if
you're in the workplace and someone says
something that upsets you or offends you
you call in you go over to them and say
look what you said bothered me a bit can
we ever talk about it
and you and you resolve your things that
way calling out would be
screenshot the email put it online
let everyone know that this person is
evil and should be fired and hounded
and that's quite a good distinction to
make because that's what we used to do i
mean i've had disputes at work you know
i used to be a teacher i used to work in
a call center i've had disputes with
people
uh and i've took them to one side and
said can we discuss this and sometimes
being right and sometimes i think but
you get you reach a resolution because
we're human beings we deal with conflict
and there's no such thing as a human
relationship
that doesn't that is devoid of conflict
um but if if my initial reaction was
always
i want to see that person fall i want to
publicly shame that person
i want to suffer that's not that's not
justice that's revenge
and i think that that's what that's what
is at the heart of this and then what we
mean by cancer culture
is this general propensity to seek
vengeance
for a perceived slight that may or may
not have been a slight in the first
place it may have been just you the way
that you perceived it
that's what cancer culture is and it
happens all the time so we need to again
go back to what i said start from
scratch the idea things we shouldn't
accept
uh that the culture war is a right-wing
myth that cancer
culture does not exist that anyone
is calling for uh free speech without
any kind of consequences or criticism
none of those things are at all true and
yet they are stated as though they are
true and this comes back to a very
important problem that we face and they
gave us a word for it didn't they the
word is gaslighting
that so many people on the identitarian
left love to gaslight they would love
they will happily say to you
this is a thing that is happening when
it is not happening or this is the thing
that's not happening when it plainly is
happening they would just
deny observable observable reality
uh and they will keep denying of the
observable reality so that you start to
doubt your own sanity that's what
gaslighting means comes from the film
gaslight you know where
the guy is constantly lowering the
lights and his wife saying why is it
getting so dim in here and he's saying
it's not
it's just you you know so that's what
that's what they do
and yet again they accuse others of
gaslighting
because that's what they do